[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 las
activistas salvadoreñas exigen a las
autoridades que se investiguen los casos
de desapariciones de mujeres y niñas por
razones de género
el colectivo alerta a raquel lo
conforman jóvenes voluntarias que se
dedican a compartir alertas en redes
sociales sobre niñas y mujeres las
víctimas están lejos de recibir atención
integral y las familias son dejadas a su
suerte en una búsqueda sin fin de sus
hijas sus hermanas sus mamás de acuerdo
con alertar a quien se han emitido 102
alertas de mujeres desaparecidas entre
los 4 y los 42 años en lo que va del
el salvador atraviesa desde hace varios
años una preocupante crisis en materia
de seguridad mientras que los homicidios
se han reducido históricamente en el
país centroamericano los casos de
desaparecidos han alarmado a la
población este año el promedio diario de
desapariciones reportadas se sitúa en 62
de esas personas son mujeres según
consta en registros del ministerio
público para organizaciones de derechos
humanos del estado no atiende de manera
pronta e integral esta problemática por
eso se creó alerta a raquel el informe
desde nuestro corresponsal vladimir
tovar con esta camisa fue ella imelda
desapareció hace más de dos años desde
entonces entre dolor y llanto la madre
sale a las calles a buscar el paradero
de su joven hija
yo lo que quieres saber de ella es en lo
que yo quiero
para que yo estaré en paz que mi corazón
esté en paz esa misma paz es la que
anhela la familia de raquel otra joven
desaparecida desde el 2019
su historia inspiró a un grupo de
feministas a crear una alerta en redes
sociales para agilizar y visibilizar la
búsqueda de mujeres desaparecidas
una alerta es un paso nada más en un
protocolo de búsqueda de una persona
pero si consideramos que ayuda mucho a
visibilizar las a sensibilizar a las
personas de la desaparición de mujeres
recuerde alertar a que las integrantes
del colectivo son voluntarias y se
turnan para generar las alertas
comunicarse con la familia ofrecer
asesoría jurídica y apoyo psicosocial
según datos oficiales diariamente se
reportan al menos dos mujeres
desaparecidas en el país la mitad son
adolescentes
hay ciertas situaciones que viven las
mujeres en las comunidades y dentro de
sus casas que llevan a vivir violencias
que terminan en una desaparición y al
ser encontradas nos damos cuenta que han
sido víctimas de feminicidio el
activismo de este colectivo traspasa las
redes también las calles son cajas de
resonancia para la denuncia
que no nos gane el día a día sin darnos
cuenta de problemáticas que están
afectando a muchas familias a muchas
familias de mujeres y que nadie les da
una respuesta el estado no está
respondiendo a esto el salvador es un
país peligroso y hostil para la búsqueda
de personas desaparecidas y el coraje de
alerta raquel es importante para
recordar que las víctimas siguen
presentes mientras no sean encontradas
y la conversación sobre este tema tan
delicado es con cristian aquino
coordinadora del equipo de respuesta
rápida de alerta raquel cristian
bienvenida a ellas hoy y amnistía
internacional considera el salvador o
como uno de los países más peligrosos
del mundo para las mujeres en 2016 y
2017 registró tasas de feminicidio de 16
y 12 por cada 100.000 habitantes ahora
en pandemia las cifras son invisibles
como es que está clear el feminicidio
aliviaría estas cifras de desapariciones
bueno el tema desapariciones con los
feminicidios en el salvador están
íntimamente ligados no podemos de dos
pisos llegar la violencia social
generalizada que vivimos como país del
forma de violencia de género vivimos las
mujeres no salvados hablar de
feminicidio y de desapariciones implica
una práctica que utilizan los
feminicidas para dejar impunes sujetos
hacia sus parejas hacia sus
a cualquier mujer que ellos pues
asesinen tiene que ver con el tema de la
impunidad entonces hablar de
feminicidios en el salvador también es
hablar de desapariciones no se pueden
disociar por lo tanto las políticas
públicas que éste dirijan y las
aplicaciones de las leyes que se han
logrado en el salvador en materia de
derechos humanos de las mujeres deben
ser aplicados el tema de las
desapariciones los ministerios están en
las medias del salvador pero las
desapariciones no están
como una parte de la violencia de género
pero vimos en el salvador por lo tanto
hablar de estos ministerios y de
combatir la impunidad en el tema de
feminicidios también contribuiría a que
las desapariciones entre mujeres en el
trabajador también se reduzcan y si no
se trabajan de esa forma pues vemos como
los los ministerios por los homicidios
bajan pero la tema de las desapariciones
joven
están íntimamente relacionadas sobre eso
uno de los llamados de alerta raquel es
evitar comentarios misóginos cargados
hacia las mujeres y que revictimizan a
las familias que buscan a las
desaparecidas cuáles son esos
comentarios y por qué necesitamos
erradicar los
el la revictimización de las de las
mujeres desaparecidas en el salvador
tiene que ver con que estiba aparecen
con vida
aparecen sin vida tienen que ver el
hecho de que siempre se culpabiliza las
mujeres por tu desaparición es también
se culpabilice está su familia por la
destapar hispanas de ellas y esté
siempre ahí como el tema de
estigmatización de las mujeres y en
fundación donde éste va viendo que la
mujer es la culpable de que porque se
busca la pareja que se busca porque
permite en los niveles de violencia qué
que vive en su hogar también por la
forma en que se viste por la forma en
que sale a las calles y se busca ser
víctima de violencia de víctima
desaparición que se fue con el novio que
por qué se buscan los maridos porque las
adolescentes también buscan tener pareja
tan pequeñas entonces como que nos trata
las mujeres somos culpables de la
violencia que recibimos y no se trata
del problema de fondo que también tiene
que ver con una cultura machista de
discriminación hacia las mujeres y donde
los hombres nos creen su de su propiedad
y objeto que ellos pueden hacer con
nuestros cuerpos los niños quieren verde
entonces es por eso que también pedimos
que la sociedad en general no emita
estos comentarios en el mixto déjenos y
marchistas donde se culpabiliza que
nosotras somos culpables de las
desapariciones y de los feminicidios por
buscarlas hace buscamos por caminar en
la calle
horas a cualquier hora de la noche o por
la forma en que nos vestimos etcétera
etcétera o por las relaciones de pareja
que entablamos entonces no se puede
digamos nuestro poder
culpabilizar y revictimizar y también
teniendo en cuenta que las mamás las
madres son las que buscan a sus hijas y
también las culpabilizan a ellas por la
educación que le dan las costillas
teniendo en cuenta que nosotros tal
estamos en un sistema y que no es culpa
de la familia en sí sino de todo lo que
de todo lo que como social tenemos
de sting mágina discriminadas puedes
hasta las mujeres ya y así entonces cómo
debería ser la atención integral a las
víctimas
bueno en el salvador hay una deuda muy
grande en cuanto a la atención a
víctimas en general de la violencia se
están generalizadas también es
importante mencionar que las víctimas de
desaparición ya están encontradas con
vida o las familias de las que siguen
buscando a su desaparecidas no son
atendidas de ninguna forma son ignoradas
por el sistema judicial en sus casos no
son resueltos no tienen acceso a la
justicia ya la verdad y tampoco tienen
acceso a asistencia psicosocial por
ejemplo donde se atiendan estos duelos y
tampoco hay un apoyo económico para las
familias desaparecidas que tienen que
ver su economía y el tema del cuidado
recargado en otras mujeres y el estado
no está respondiendo de ninguna forma no
hay una forma de seguimiento hay un
protocolo las urgentes para búsqueda y
que no es aplicado al 100% y que las
familias tampoco están enteradas de cómo
es pues este protocolo por lo tanto la
atención a víctimas hasta el salvador es
una deuda grandísima desde el momento en
que anunciamos hasta el momento en que
éste sigue la búsqueda porque se cierra
este sello después de 30 días y no hemos
encontrado a la víctima y no hay un
seguimiento no hay una atención
económica ni psicológica y jurídica de
ninguna forma y para el colmo también
nos tenemos que cargar el estigma de las
propiedades por lo tanto la casta una
víctima debe estar de una forma integral
y tener en cuenta que las víctimas no
sólo es la persona que es para aparearse
sino también por familia equipos
fumadores y que también deben ser
atendidos conforme al delito al que
activo víctima sobre eso le quería
preguntar huici arma como es la
desaparición para las familias como daña
esa incertidumbre pues de no saber si su
ser amado está vivo o muerto porque a
ellas finalmente las parió una madre las
amaron unos hijos o unos padres tienen
toda una red
que ya no existe para ellas
y realmente ese es el trasfondo tan
doloroso que hay detrás de una
desaparición y sobre todo de las
desapariciones que no tienen un
resultado y no tienen un acceso a la
verdad ya la justicia es una situación
muy dolorosa sobre todo para las madres
las tías las abuelas personas que
estaban buscando hasta el final cuando
ya las instituciones ya no gustan más
son ellas las que están buscando las que
estaban esperando las estelas anginas
también las amigas en el caso de raquel
las amigas también están
pues viviendo es a ese dolor y el
presente a diario y siguen esperando por
días y por años y no y no tienen
respuestas por lo tanto está en la parte
más dolorosa y la parte más inhumana de
no abordar el tema de la desaparición y
quizá muchas gracias a ustedes por estar
con nosotros y para finalizar solo acuñó
una frase de alerta raquel hace mucho
que no están y aún las seguimos buscando
sigan en france24
[Música]